Let's do it.
Anybody have a question?
- [Man] Who are the influencers
that you like
listening to right now?
Are you listening to anyone or
are you just making up your own
stuff and you're good with that?
- Yeah.
(group laughter)
I genuinely, this is
like a straight up thing,
and you know it's funny,
did you guys see that
I posted my report card.
- [Group] Yeah.
That was a really interesting
insight to me which is I just
didn't realize how many
people didn't believe me.
I just continue to
not be believed.
It's my life.
I think people
think I'm exaggerating.
I think people thought I was a
B and C student and that was
really interesting
insight to me.
When I tell you that I've never
listen to anybody, I could not
tell you, I've never read a
line, a line of Seth Godin
content in my life and so
I genuinely believe with my
whole heart that that has
a lot to do with why I do well.
'Cause if you're consuming,
you're regurgitating and
everybody is consuming the same
shit and so I think the reason
I don't think I'm that smart.
I just think I say the same
stuff as other people I just
think that because I don't know
how it's actually said I came up
with my way of saying it and
that just might've worked for
people because they just
heard it a different way.
I genuinely believe that.
- [Man] Yeah.
- And so I think
that's interesting
and so I protect that.
I think I protected it through
school by getting D's and F's
and I think I protected
through the way I run my life
which is I consume you.
I consume your reactions you
know and that gives me insight.
So yeah, I don't really listen.
I don't need anything, you know?
- [Man] Is that what you
prescribe for other people too?
- If they can pull it off.
I just think I'm dramatically
more talented than other people.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Man 2] What's it look
like for you to balance
business and family as well?
- It's a moving target and
I haven't always done it well.
You guys, for the hardest core
of you, you guys have heard me
say like I regret the first
five years of my marriage.
We should've went, I wish I had
those memories of those
seven to 10 vacations. You know?
But it helped me do a
better job with the kids.
You know?
I don't have those regrets.
I'm pumped that I started my day
today at 10 and watched
Misha and Xander's assembly.
You know something that I don't
know if I would've done 12 years
ago, so it's a moving target and
the truth is for anybody that's
struggling with it or thinking
about it, it just only works the
way everything works which
is constant communication.
What Lizzie cares about is
different today than what she
cared about yesterday
let alone two years ago.
- [Man 3] First off,
thanks for having us here.
Appreciate it.
- [Gary] No worries.
- So what's your thought--
- It was funny, when I did
that offer I was like what's the
best, (stammering)
did anybody do the same
thing with Thank You Economy?
Was anybody around
for all of that?
So with Thank You Economy I did
a similar thing like buy this
thing and something's gonna
happen, buy the books and
we sent a thank you box.
Right, we just sent the book
but was like $100 with the shit
which was like more
than the books cost.
I was like proud you
know like that was good.
They've got more stuff but
I was like what's, you know,
the number one asset is access.
People are willing to fly from
fucking Australia, you know?
Alaska.
- [Woman] I actually
said to my husband--
- You must've so pissed right?
I've said Georgia and she's
like, "Australia" and she's like
"Fuck."
(group laughter)
That's awesome.
- [Alex] There's somebody coming
from Ireland who's not here yet.
- [Gary] Wow.
- [Alex] They're literally
coming from the airport.
- Amazing.
Yeah, brother.
- Question was can you break
down your thought process
when you enter a room?
How do you break
down the situation?
How do you analyze, how do you
choose what actually pertains?
- That's interesting.
I come in blank.
It's why I like Q&amp;A.
I come in blank
and super confident.
And I stay to my shit.
Boy, will I not reach.
You know this is a really
interesting transformation even
for me the last year because
obviously my profile is much
stronger than it was a year ago
today and I've been around for a
decade digitally so I've been
like, I've been noticed and in
the game since 2006 but
between the contents...
It's so funny when everybody,
anybody razzes me on social like
especially Instagram where my
strategy has been very quote
driven and very rah-rah the most
version of myself there because
it's just the medium that
I think it's right for, right?
So there more than anywhere
else because fucking Facebook is
really detailed with the show
and other things, there I'll get
the occasional like, "All right,
I get it hustle like
"fucking give me a detail."
And I always get so pissed at
that person because I'm like,
"You're such a fucking idiot.
"I'm giving you
details every day.
"Watch me, don't listen to me.
"Do what I'm doing.
"It will work,
it works every time."
So you know, I don't even
know why I went there but
the punchline is
I stay in my lane.
I know what I'm talking about,
about what I'm talking about
and so what I'm pretty
good at actually is forcing
the room to go in my direction.
If I walked into a room and the
conversation was gonna be about
SEO because they're like, "Hey,
I hear Vayner's doing everything
"and we really want
talk about SEO."
I'll energy-wise push them into
Facebook and social, you know?
It's what I want to talk about.
So I keep it on my turf and then
so yeah I actually think
I can break this down.
I keep it on my turf but then
everything else is about them.
That's the non-debatable.
It's gonna be on my turf.
Now, tell me what you want.
Even this.
There was no
debate of the format.
There was no like how do
you guys want to do this.
This is what we're gonna do,
now everything else about you.
Got it?
- [Man 3] Do you ever
have to go on defense?
Or you just have the
ball in your court?
- I'm never on defense.
I'll bail, I'll bail.
When I when I was dating, if I
saw anything that wasn't in,
if I dated so
I hated negativity.
It's why we have
a great culture.
If I dated a girl that
I realized very quickly like
she liked, it was intriguing
to have conflict,
I literally bailed immediately.
Out forever.
I have no effort for defense.
I'm trying to win every
game 477 to 433 and
I'm talking about baseball.
You know what I mean?
- [Man 4] I don't watch baseball
but yeah.
- But you know what you mean?
But baseball where
there's lower scoring.
That's why that's the analogy.
Fucking soccer.
I'm trying to score
so many points
that I'm not worried
about the casualties.
You know this more because
you've been at Vayner like
I never care about the
failures at Vayner.
I love when people come
in to me and be like,
"Listen I've got to talk to
you about this problem.
"It's really gonna
undermine us."
I'm like, "Are you
a fucking idiot?
"How the fuck you
think we got here?
"If you want me to
play your micro game,
"I'm gonna look
like everybody else."
So I'm always on the offense,
always macro and always very
aware of what I want to happen.
- [Man 5] So with that you're
running a old school business
model and scaling it.
- [Gary] Because I--
- [Man 5] This is an old
school business model.
- 100%.
- [Man 5] Old school,
like not new school with
new school technologies.
- Every internet friend I had
texted me that I was a fucking
idiot for starting VaynerMedia.
- [Man 5] And this move
is an old school move and
it's a huge risk.
- What's a risk?
- [Man 5] Taking on a building
and the amount of people.
How are you
scaling the unscalable?
- By wrecking--
- [Man 5] This is unscalable
to everyone's imagination.
- Right.Because I recognize
that that's my strength.
My strength is people.
My strength is marketing.
- How do you teach this
young crowd old school?
Because most of them don't look
like they got out of college.
- You'd be stunned how many of
the young kids have old school
tactics and beliefs and how many
of the old school have
young school tactics.
It's not an age thing,
it's a DNA thing.
- Ah, so you're
hiring DNA that way.
- We're trying.
- Some.
- By the way, no, no,
we're firing people that
don't have the DNA.
- I get it.
That's smart.
- People are crippled by heart,
I mean look you up insight.
Throw it in here.
You've been around.
- [Woman 2] I've been at a lot
of different ad agencies
and this is by far
the most amazing place
I've worked at.
- Because, of course
it's true because
I fire all the bad people.
(group laughter)
And by the way,
if you're here for a week
and you're in that moment,
you know somebody can
hide you for even a year.
We're at scale.
They may be able to, you know,
kind of get away with it for a
little while but not for real.
You know I mean?
And a year is
probably impossible.
Six months, yes.
So the answer is 'cause
that's what I'm good at.
You know that was the punchline,
let me build like do you know
how impossible this
company is to beat.
I got the craziest
email from a recruiter.
Like the craziest which was,
"I've been trying to recruit
"from your company, we were
put on assignment to steal your
"people by a competitor,
we got zero."
He's like, "We've
never seen this before.
"Can we work with you?"
So I just thought I could do it.
It's really no different than
like you know like being the
best basketball player or singer
like I don't know that
sounds hard. You know?
So scalability doesn't scare
me because people have scaled
people for many years, we're
just in the tech age where it
doesn't seem as cool.
You know?
- [Man 6] You're
winning here so...
- Hell yeah.
- [Woman] Just on that growth thing,
I don't know how big or
small our businesses are
but going from that kind of
lifestyle where your business is
creating cash and
you've got small team
to going to a much larger
performance business where
potentially there's a bit in
the middle where it's desert.
Cash flow dries up
and profit goes down.
- [Gary] Yes.
- I've got a great
lifestyle business that
generates a stack of cash.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And I want to performance
business but I know there's this
hideous desert in the middle and
I'm gonna get through that as
quickly as possible.
You've done that a
couple of times.
- [Gary] Yes, I have.
- What would--
- [Gary] What's the punchline?
- Yep.
Other than all the stuff
that I know you already say.
- The punchline is all the stuff
that you know that
I already say.
(group laughter)
Which is those three years
are not just gonna be as fun.
- [Woman] Yeah and do it fast.
- But also respect that
it might take some time.
- [Woman] No different--
- You're such a young woman.
What's wrong with
too, yeah that's fine.
You're such a young woman like
what's wrong with
two years in between?
- [Woman] Nothing.
- By the way, that's it.
- [Woman] Yeah, okay.
- We're gonna make less money
this year at $100 million than
we made last year at $67.
Net.
I don't mean percentage.
- [Man 5] Why?
- Because I'm getting greedier.
Meaning they're in trouble.
Them.
(group laughter)
I see it which means
I over-invested.
More people,
more capabilities
because I'm gonna take
the whole fucking pie.
You know what I mean?
I'm not worried about how much
cash I'm gonna take home in 2016
because I can take
a lot more in 2020.
It's much more fun to take
home $44 million in 2020
than $3 million in
2017, '18 and '19.
Instead of $4 million.
People are, 99% of the
market is short term.
And the 1% that isn't and has
the talent wins every time.
Which makes no sense because
unless you're gonna die
you should only play long term.
There was a stat that some dude
in Mexico City said one of these
futurist type characters,
I'm sure he's smart.
I have no idea who so I just but
he was right before me as
I was mic'd up and he says,
"It's been
scientifically proven,"
so I don't know if it has or not
because I've learned to take
that with a grain of salt but
"that 85% of what
"humans make
decisions about is irrational."
And that spoke to me.
Because A,
I think it's higher
and B, it's why I think all
my success is happening.
I am stunningly the most
rational and the most practical
of all yet I don't seem it.
And when he said it I'm like,
"Right, that's why."
"Because the rest of the
market is irrational."
- [Man 7] I always
find it intriguing
of how people share their
story about discovering you.
My friend was
interviewed by Marie Forleo.
and you were the
next video on the cue
being interviewed
when Jeb came out,
so I was, all right,
who the hell is this?
That's it,
I was a follower then.
Do you still take that mentality
of being everywhere?
- Yes, never too fancy.
- [Man 7] Like eight
view podcast or whatever
when there's
not a book involved?
- Yes.
- [Man 7] Okay.
Because the
potential of being in front
of everyone that doesn't
even know who you are
is like, just crazy.
- It is crazy.
Or is it?
(group laughter)
- [Man 7] There's
plenty of people opening up
fast food things with two
million YouTube followers,
I think we could bump your
number up a little bit.
- You know what's funny,
I think you know
this at this point,
I really mean that
I don't give a fuck.
Three hundred thirty thousand?
Mazel tov.
And?
- [Man 7] And they're
the most loyal followers too.
- And if not?
I'm gonna make
more money than PewDiePie.
(group laughter)
- Honey, empire.
Honey, empire.
They both matter.
- [Man 8] And how
do you maintain that?
- By making all my
actions honey and empire.
And then letting the people
that are capable stay
and letting the people
that are not capable
either choose or
be forced to leave.
- [Man 8] So empower
them with that decision?
- Binary.
Hang on here
because I want you to get it.
Through my actions.
That's it.
I sent an email to
140 employees this week
asking for who the
strongest and the weakest
employee was
that they work with.
It sent garbage
through our company.
People emailing
that we've changed.
People emailing,
websites to post it.
Fear.
Gave me an indication on
who's scared, who's not.
Who understands, who doesn't.
Everybody boxes everything
in and creates context,
which means they
then lose context.
The reason I scale so well
is every behavior I do
is predicated on
creating the most context
from the reaction to my action.
Yeah it's like, I don't
even know what that means,
but probably.
(group laughter)
I'm being dead serious,
I really don't.
But you know what I mean?
Even an indicator of like,
it's interesting,
the people I don't know,
the people I do know,
why they're here,
it's all context building.
I'm obsessed with context.
I'm the greatest listener
you've ever met
it's just that I talk so
much nobody realized it.
- So you say, which
I'm trying to recalibrate
my brain around to,
you love losing?
- [Gary] Love it.
You know why?
- No.
- [Gary] Because I don't
care how anybody
judges my losses.
You only care
about losing because
you care about what other
people think about your loss.
- [Man 9] And so
on that note,
because I saw you at Traffic
Conversion Show in San Diego.
- [Gary] Yes,
that was a good one.
- It was, it was the
first time I saw you.
- [Gary] Did you know
who I was before?
- Sorry?
- [Gary] Did you know who
I was before I took the stage?
- No, no.
- [Gary] That's the best!
- And so immediately my
wife and I were driving home
from San Diego to
Orange County and we started
figuring out that
you had a podcast.
And so I went back in
time to the first one
all the way up to
the ones you have now,
like 200 something.
- [Gary] I appreciate it.
So what did you
take away from it?
Like in that kind of a binge,
coming from zero context,
what was like the...
- The biggest thing...
- [Gary] The greatest
human ever?
(group laughter)
- That was one of them.
I have no idols
myself but you were one
that I would say
is like the closest,
because you were doing
exactly what I would do.
And I have a mini, mini agency,
I'm not anywhere close to
anything of what you're doing.
- [Gary] And you know
what so crazy about that?
Even the way you hedge
it, it means nothing.
Right?
Like, I love, I'm always
fascinated by what,
I appreciate the humility.
It's so interesting that
we do that as humans.
Like even
context shit like that.
Keep going.
- [Man 9] I almost
lost my train of thought.
- [Gary] I already
lost it once today.
- One of the biggest
takeaways that you mention,
and this is not even a question
I just want to say thank you,
is the net/net thing,
of like all the
small things you lose
but in the big picture.
Like 99% of the
things don't matter.
- [Gary] Dude, I swear
on the New York Jets,
which I've never lied
on in my entire life,
I genuinely only care about
the health of my family.
It's so crazy you couldn't
even wrap your head around it.
Do you know how
many copies of a book
of how VaynerMedia went
from a hundred million
to going out of
business I could sell?
All of them.
It's a no lose game for me.
It's not scary.
- [Man 10] One of
the recent DailyVee's
you mention that it's like
the hockey stick curve,
the last six months, what
was it 500K subscribers.
- [Gary] Oh Facebook.
- [Man 10] Yeah,
your team, where you
analyze the metrics
and the analytics.
I know your context
has been insane lately.
- It's the five or six
videos that go ballistic
that change the outcome.
The fucking intern
video went insane-o.
It's so crazy,
it's actually two new demos
for me on some level.
You can tell Danny if
he wants to hang he can.
The urban market,
because the Breakfast Club.
Right, hip hop,
African American, Latino,
just hip hop heads,
like sneaker heads.
Breakfast Club went viral,
those clips
with Cha The God, right viral.
So a lot more urban.
And the intern video,
and much younger.
That's it!
Two huge new demos
that a video that got
20, 30 million reach
on Facebook created.
Facebook's television guys.
You're one video away
from changing your life.
People just don't believe it.
People are also not
willing to make a video
everyday always constantly.
And most importantly,
and this is just straight up,
most people aren't
capable of producing
content everyday
that's interesting,
good, thoughtful,
entertaining, fascinating,
pretty, like it's hard.
I think I said it today,
did I say it today?
Did I say it today on social?
Talent or I made a video...
DRock, help me.
(audience laughs)
Where did I do that?
Talent is (stammers)
Oh, the interview!
- [DRock] Yeah.
(clicks tongue)
Talent, guys talent.
Talent's real,
it's a real thing.
- [Man 11] Which
platform has
your most responsive audience?
If you ask a yes or no question
who responds the
most and the fastest?
- I think the attention
is deepest on Snapchat.
I really do, by like percentage.
You know Facebook...
You know what's so funny?
Back to the analytics,
I'm in the branding business
and all of you guys are
in the sales business.
And once you understand
what I mean by that
that's where the
whole thing unlocks.
Everybody's into the sales.
What I mean by that is,
everybody's trying
to look at the tactics.
I'm in the religion.
The reason I don't know is
because I'm playing forever
and I'm building brand.
It just doesn't matter.
- [Man 12] You
talked about that...
- By the way,
I'll give you a go in a sec,
if that was the way
the game was played
everybody's looking
at the metrics.
If this was math
it would've been
figured out a long time ago,
you need to let that go.
Math gets you rich.
You can figure out a conversion,
a landing page optimization,
a moment in time.
Math doesn't
get you what I want.
- [Man 13] So when
we coach we talk about,
gotta have perspectives
to see kind of what
the athletes doing.
They're gonna have their
vision coaching wise.
You've got to have attention.
If you can't get them
to pay attention to you,
you're screwed.
- Yeah.
- The next thing is direction.
You have perspective talent,
you have the ability
to see things that
probably a lot of us miss.
We get that.
You definitely have our
attention though,
now we're looking at you
saying we want to mirror it.
We might not be able to
keep it the same pace
- [Gary] A version
of it for myself.
I push that hard.
I want to make
sure that everybody
gets their version of it,
around what they want.
I hate when kids are like
"I want to buy
the Cavaliers now!"
I'm like did you before?
(laughter)
- They're missing
the point though.
- [Gary] They're
missing the point.
- Yeah the people
that are talking...
- [Gary] That's right.
- So you have
our attention and that's
probably got them too.
- [Gary] Yes.
- What's the direction now?
What's the next move?
Because you're pushing it-
- [Gary] From me or
through you guys to you?
- Through us.
- [Gary] Self awareness.
- Can't give that.
- [Gary] No?
- [Man 12] Can't
give that though.
- Yeah. Well I don't want
to give you anything else.
You know what I mean?
I just...
You have to understand.
Advice is a shit business.
Because you lack context.
I mean do you know how much
context to give you real advice
I would need?
In this setting?
Is your dad sick?
Did your mom leave your dad?
Do you have a sibling
that's fucking crushing it
and always did?
Do you have,
there's so much context
I actually need
to give the direction
that I would feel good about,
that'd I'd rather in a world
where everybody's selling
"tactics" and "advice"
and "direction"
I'm going to be
an ungodly force of nature
against leveling up the
thinking at every moment.
And then through my actions,
hoping that you guys pick up
on them and replicate them.
- [Man 12] And then answering
the other question
that I propose.
Schedule wise for business
what's the direction now?
If you push us to buy a
book, we're gonna buy a book.
- [Gary] Yes.
- You've got our attention.
- You say hey buy the product,
small business VanynerMedia
we'll buy it right now.
- [Gary] I don't want
you guys, not yet.
- Because we're new compared
to the other people.
(laughter)
- [Gary] No!
Dude think about this,
you know this.
There's more money in it
for me to go after you than
the other...
- [Man 12] The
volumes there.
- Are you kidding?
- [Man 12] But you
haven't done it.
You do it once ever two
years on a book for 12 bucks.
- Right.
I just don't need it right now.
And I say right now,
I mean I've contemplated.
I want to.
I want to create a
VaynerMedia SaaS product
that's $5000 a month,
that helps you.
I just don't have it yet.
I can't take your
$60,000 if I don't have it.
But if I have it,
I'll give it to you.
Because you'll win.
So VaynerTALENT,
that you might have
saw in the last episode,
that's going to be
a huge department.
Everybody wants to be me.
There's people in here
that actually would
pay $25,000 for me to do it.
They feel like they
can make the math work.
To have their
DRock and my machine.
Here's the punchline...
It will work.
So that's cool.
So I feel good about,
that'd be the first time
I enter into slightly
that territory, truth is
I'm gonna hold it off.
'Cause I still
don't want to go there.
I'll do it with you know...
Tyra Banks.
You know?
But if I can get there I would.
I only sell what I'm proud of.
I'm obsessed with selling stuff.
Like stuff.
This Amazon arbitrage is real.
This eBay arbitrage is real.
Like I don't know how
much money she needs,
but I can tell you it is scary.
Scary.
If she's willing to study
eBay three hours a night
for three months, then
I think she can make
$100,000 a year going to
thrift stores and garage sales.
That's cool.
Easy.
Easier than anybody would know.
- [Man 13] He did it last
week on SnapChat with-
- You know like it's...
And by the way books.
Books.
On Amazon.
There's that dude
whose a fan of mine
who claims he's making $600,000,
he's probably hit your
radar maybe here or there.
Like I don't know he's some guy,
if you see on YouTube he
gets paid like $600,000
selling books last year.
He went all in.
He just goes
to every thrift store,
takes his fucking phone out,
scans every fucking book.
Sees the velocities,
so it means they'll sell,
because you don't want to
get caught with inventory.
Has feel for if
it will actually sell
and then he sees it
sells for $23 on average
and it's a dollar at the
fucking Goodwill and he buys it.
And he did that scale.
Because if you work 18
hours, some people can't.
Like I get it.
Which is why I don't judge.
I walked to Kmart to buy
shit for $4 with my mom.
Like, I've got context.
I know.
And guess what
I don't even really know,
because both my parents lost
a parent before they were 15.
Like I've had it good,
for my humble beginnings.
Who am I?
I'm not judging anybody.
But I'm not going to make it
convenient for you either.
That's what I believe.
Because I know
who buys that shit.
Do you understand?
- [Woman 4] Yeah.
- And that fucking hurts me too.
I'm just not gonna pick
you over the other person.
I'm just not.
So, by the way,
people can say
anything they want,
and do anything they want
and they should.
But that is my truth.
And you're right you don't need
to be the player
to be the coach,
that's only one of the 40
things that sit on my head.
- [Man 14] Yeah I agree
with you, yeah.
I mean you've got to be well
100% believe in
what you're selling.
- But I have the luxury
to believe in what I sell.
Like I said, I would steal food
faster than you could blink.
If I had to.
For my kids, if I had no money.
And I would,
I swear to God I would.
Steal.
I didn't say go in the
garbage and take food,
I would do that too.
But steal too.
Life is life.
- Question on e-Commerce.
Can we talk e-Commerce?
- Of course, I'm willing to,
we can talk about anything.
- Listen to my podcast because
that's all I talk about
is e-Commerce, Amazon and
eBay and all that jazz right.
So I get people reaching
out to me all the time with
these new venues trying to sell.
- Yes.
- How do you figure
out which one has legs?
You know all these new
platforms coming out,
Amazon is you know that big.
Then eBay and Etsy and
all the rest of them.
But there's other
ones coming out.
How do you figure out
which one has legs?
- I just do them all.
- Because we
- I do them all.
- Invest
- I get it.
- So much energy and effort
to bring a product to market
in those marketplaces.
- Of course.
That's the punchline.
- That's the hard part.
- Think about how lucky you,
think about how lucky you,
no no lets play it out.
I know you know,
but let's play it out
because I want
everybody to hear this.
Think about how lucky we have it
that we're doing it digital.
Because the real estate
version of this is
which beach front property
do you think is gonna work.
But if I told you if you
had enough money
if you bet on 10 of 'em,
all you need of one of 'em
and you'll make your
money back and then some.
- So put it on all 10?
- But you know what?
I know that Peach and I know
that Anchor are out there.
And you guys have seen me.
I'll say something about Anchor,
I'll taste it for a second.
I haven't done
anything on Anchor
for fucking nine months, right.
Figure out a version
where you put in the work
to actually taste it
but you don't go so
over-committed.
Got it.
You gotta find
that right balance.
- A little bit of risk.
- It's about risk.
Do you know what
my number one asset is?
- Let me think.
Yeah, I think, well you already,
- My asset--
- Well you don't give a shit.
- No, my number one asset,
not my number one skill.
What?
- [Man] You know yourself.
- [Woman] Time.
- Time.
Time.
Time is my asset.
Right.
It's time.
And then I do all this stuff
on these platforms on spec.
Got it?
- It's on, I get it.
- Do you know how much
easier it for me to write a
$50,000 check that I gave away
to the non-profit in Canada.
Right.
I got so many e-mails about
that, I'm such a great guy.
No I'm not.
That's the easiest
non-profit work I do.
That fucking three hour
fucking meeting I have to do,
with Pencils of Promise each
month, that fucking blows.
(group laughter)
Time.
- [Man 15] What's the
most exciting thing
in your life right now?
Couple things that you
think about every day?
- That Misha is 100% got a shot
to have a bigger audience
than me in about two years.
(group laughter)
'Cause she's gonna be the
nine-year-old girl version of
me,
deployed against singing
and entertainment.
I'm really in a good
zone right now bro,
like the most exciting
thing is, I've gotten
to a really tight
zone around health,
family and business,
and it's tight.
- [Man 15] (mumbles)
- Yeah, it's goin' right.
(everyone laughing)
You know, like really tight,
you know?
Real tight.
More family time than ever,
working harder
and stronger than ever,
and feeling better than ever.
So, it's gonna play itself out.
And don't forget,
Lizzy married me.
So it's not like she's foreign
to it, or scared of it,
you know what I mean?
So, Lizzy's super
capable with that.
Now, the difference is,
supporting, at the time, a
30-year-old male's version
into that game versus
a nine-year-old girl's
version is very different.
So, different dynamics, right?
Like, you're gettin'
the theme of this talk,
from me at least, is like,
it's just so many details,
you know?
Like, there'll be a
million variables there.
Like, most of Misha's
friends are on Musically,
and she's not, I mean, that's
the irony of it all, isn't it?
- Why is she not?
Do you know why?
- 'Cause Lizzy
doesn't want her on there.
- Okay.
- [Man 15] And that's
what I deal with the kids,
I deal with the dynamic
between the parent,
not allowing it, and the
frustration between the kid
having social dynamic
differences because of it.
It changes.
- There's real stuff out there.
But there always has been.
Do you know how scared I was
that Russia was
gonna drop a nuclear bomb
on America when
I was in third grade?
I thought about it
every day of my life.
I swear to God.
There's always
somethin' to be scared of.
I'm just not scared 'cause
I'm just the most practical.
More people will die
in America this year
by being struck by
lightning than terrorism.
I know it's true.
It's just data, not super hard.
It's not convenient or
interesting or
a fun thing to say,
it's the truth.
- [Man 16] There's nothin'
you can do about it,
so why worry?
- It's not even that, it's
just like, but nobody,
like, I mean, there's
entire gen, there's fuckin',
hundred million people
walkin' around America
scared of terrorists,
like fearful, scared.
My mother-in-law
is scared shitless.
- [Woman] It's more
dangerous crossing a road.
- 'Specially the way
I do it, I don't even look!
- [Man 15] Your rationality
is pretty slim.
- [Man 16] DailyVee,
I think it was 80,
the live stream
goes out last week?
- [Gary] 80 the long one?
- Yeah, so, one of my
favorites, well the favorite,
well actually
Salty Vee was my favorite.
(group laughter)
Yeah, with the whole talk
at the end, I don't know
what that was all about.
There was a meeting
you were in, and I've
been thinking about it since,
and you got
on this little rant
with him about--
- [Gary] A hamster wheel?
- A hamster wheel, and
how you close the door
and go to Mars and
never come back--
- [Gary] And by the way like
the only, like, just real quick
'cause I don't know
if you caught it.
I said it before he said it,
because I just listen
to what people, you know?
It's so interesting.
Go ahead.
- Okay, you slam the
doors, you go to Mars,
you never come back, you
wish that on no one, ever.
- [Gary] 'Cause it's so scary.
- But, what I'm tryin'
to figure out was,
what did that mean?
- [Gary] What did that mean?
- What were you talking about?
- When you are so pot commit,
I care about capitalism,
and meritocracy, and the game,
more than I care about myself.
And that is crazy shit.
And I really don't see it,
and I, only 'cause I haven't
gotten close to it or figured
out how to see it in others,
but it is a different thing.
When you get to that
level of selflessness,
it's a vulnerability that
is so extreme, and it just,
it's so, I mean, I just
think I'm cut out for it,
and I don't wanna force
my audience into it,
because their behaviour
probably hasn't been
their whole life to be in it.
Got it?
- [Man 16] Yeah.
- Like it's crazy to be four
foot 11 your freshman year
of high school,
and still think you're
the best looking, most popular.
(group laughter)
Like, to be against the
market, is, my life is playing
against the market.
It's just, something
happened in the way that
the world works, that is
working very much in my favor.
But wouldn't have 30 years ago?
The market was
closed 30 years ago.
- [Man 16] When you
were at Icon your talk, it,
huge breakthrough for me,
you already know
it's a breakthrough, you know
the stuff, you say it makes
a difference in people's
lives, but you were talkin'
about what you were
talkin' about earlier.
That, if you're in the
long game, you're not in it
for the short term, make a sale
right here,
but you're in it
for the long game.
- [Gary] Yeah that was an interesting
vibe I took at that conference,
'cause I knew there was
a lot of sales people.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] And I was coming
with marketing.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- It was right on for
where, for where I was at
in particular, because
I was in the middle
of capitalizing on
everything that I know,
and putting it in a way that
I could scale the things
that I'm best at, right?
Things that I'm good at,
and I kept thinking like,
I can't be here, I can't be
there, but if I'm in front
of people, that's when
I'm at my best.
And so when you started
talking about, look,
I'm not here for the short
thing, I wanna do a product,
like you said here, I wanna
do it, but I'm not ready
to do it yet because
I haven't figured it out yet.
And so this isn't so much more
of a question, other than,
I would just like to hear
you talk a little bit more
about whatever's on the
top of your brain right now
in regards to
your personal brand.
What you think about each
day when it comes to that,
and I dunno, however you've
evolved since that time,
'cause that was powerful.
- It was always there.
- It changed the game.
- I've been able to start
articulating, you know,
it's really interesting,
even my early business talks,
if you've dug up some
of those things, like,
I wasn't so, like,
I wasn't there yet.
Like, I just, you know,
you learn from experience,
like, I mean, it's one move.
Where's the attention,
how do I create
for that medium,
deploy the message.
At scale.
One person scale.
Every day work, every day work.
You know?
That's it man, it's really.
- [Man 16] Do you
think about that, or is it--
- I think about that,
and nothing else.
And not my Facebook data.
And not my followers.
My self-esteem is not wrapped up
in my 604,000
Instagram followers.
'Cause there's some dude with
awesome abs that has 900,000.
(group laughter)
Like, that's just
not a smart game.
- [Man 16] So I really
honestly--
- I'm the most basic
thing you've ever seen.
- [Man 16] Your central
thought is, I'll just be me,
and I'll be damn
good at doin' it.
- Because I'm damn good
at business and marketing
and selling stuff, and all,
like, 'cause I'm good at that.
Again, I keep saying it,
and it's funny,
it's this whole thing that I'm,
it's why I'm like, oh wait a
minute, I can do this forever.
'Cause nobody believes me!
- [Man 16] Yeah.
- You know, like, I built a
business, a real business,
before I started talking.
And it was against odds.
$3,000,000, I love when
people razz me on social
and say, but his dad
gave him a $3,000,000,
a $3,000,000 business that
does 10% gross profit,
which is $300,000,
before expenses,
is not some fucking war chest.
Thank you business people.
(group laughter)
Do you know what I mean?
You know that I mean,
like there's
a ton of people here
making way more.
There was no, it was like,
and to build that from three
to 60 million, in five years,
took crazy talent as kid.
I didn't learn that at Warton.
And I didn't learn it
by reading Purple Cow,
I learned it
because I'm the best.
Naturally.
And now I'm just
learning how to, like,
now I'm just playing for legacy.
- [Woman] Where's the
online attention
of executives, like middle--
- LinkedIn.
Facebook.
- [Woman 2] So, with
that said--
- I just, black and
white tactics, you know?
Those two places.
- Yeah, it's really
interesting, because I,
obviously would think LinkedIn,
but we're getting more
from Facebook, more--
- Scale.
- [Woman 2] And I'm
sure you've given your version--
- Real quick, I apologize,
but you just might be a better
basketball player than you
are a wiffle ball player.
You just might not
be good at LinkedIn.
(group laughter)
Your rugby skills are better
than your cricket skills.
- [Woman 2]
What is your definition
of an entrepreneur,
because, I know nowadays
everybody--
- Nobody likes my definition.
I always get push back on this.
Just somebody who's never
worked for anybody else
in their lives.
I mean, the purest-bred
entrepreneur
couldn't breathe
with any other thing.
I barely barely walked
into my family business
when my dad gave
me the complete control
of the company right away.
But that's just mine.
Like, that's not, like, a
lot of people really hate
when I go here,
and I get a lot of push back,
and I respect that,
because it's cool to be
an entrepreneur now.
So everybody wants
to think they are.
You're not,
if you work at Pepsi.
I don't know how to cut it,
this is like when I got,
there was that one talk with
me and Casey on that Q&amp;A,
and the person asked,
like, do you think
there's a difference between
men and women, and I said yes,
and people got mad.
I'm like, how is that possible?
(group laughter)
Yes, I think there's
some differences.
I didn't say one was
better than the other,
or this and that,
I'm always laughing about that,
like, I don't know, maybe
you don't like me saying it,
but, I know enough about
school that you can go
and look up a definition, and
I haven't seen the definition
of an entrepreneur that
maps to the person
that works at
Microsoft right now,
and claims they're
an entrepreneur.
- Well, again, I just
think that I really don't,
I do tell you, I do say it.
I also don't
think it really, like,
I don't think my opinion
matters any more
than anybody else's.
I think my results
are gonna be different.
I think that will give
it clout over time.
But I'm not super
worried about it.
I'm super worried about...
I've realized that there's
something I'm
doing that's right,
I understand those things,
and I hope that they can be
a blueprint that is not copied,
but understood
contextually to yourself
and you can get
the benefits from it,
that may be the benefits
that you may need from it.
Too many people want people
to emulate them, I don't.
'Cause I know all
the weird variables
that come along with me.
I just want you to be
able to understand it,
understand yourself,
and then deploy it.
- [Woman 4] Hi Gary, I have a
question about Facebook ads.
Do you think it's more for the
brand building
or, actually,
it can convert to sales?
- [Gary] Both, it sells the
living shit out of stuff.
- Because I find people
who go to Facebook,
they're actually not
really into buying stuff.
- Wrong.
- [Man 17] People buy
stuff all day long.
- Billions of dollars of
selling, billions this year.
Most people don't
know how to do it
because they're trying to
play Google AdWords DNA
against Facebook.
- [Woman 4] Okay.
- You have a bunch of sellers
coming to a marketing platform.
- [Woman 4] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Woman 5] To continue on
the social media page,
you were very good at predicting
Twitter and all those--
- [Gary] I'm really good
at talking about it loudly
when I've decided
it's already won.
- Okay, what has
your attention right now?
Past musical.ly?
- Not much.
Marco Polo's an interesting
communication tool.
After school, I invested
in a company called One,
he pivoted,
it's called After School now,
it's doing well in high school.
Not much.
You know what's fun?
You know what
I've done really well?
I haven't forced it.
A lot of "futurists" or
"pundits" say shit
'cause they need
another headline.
I can be comfortable if
I never have another one again.
Got it?
That's the biggest
difference between
me and everybody else out
there that people think are me.
- [Woman 5] You're
just paying attention.
- Do you see how
many people said
"I told you so" about Vine?
What the fuck does that mean?
(group laughter)
I made millions of
dollars because of Vine.
(group laughter)
That's like saying, "I told
you that Empire was gonna
"eventually get cancelled."
No shit, Dick.
Hey!
- Sorry.
Good to make it,
man, how are you?
Let's get him a chair.
Go get a different angle.
- [Man 14] Could you deploy
this machine on a
- Yes, yes.
- Project and revenue?
- Do you notice how
I tried to jump in quick?
I can deploy this
machine against
changing America's
opinion about Beyonce.
- [Man 14] I know, that's
why I want that SaaS product.
- I get it.
And I promise you, I want
the 40 trillion dollars
of valuation that my
SaaS product would get,
I just really want
to feel good about it.
I really do.
Honey empire, you know?
Two very big contradictions,
but look, if you want
results that are anomaly
you have to act like one,
I've said that,
or a version of that.
That's what's happening,
I'm pumped about this, man.
I really hope
I can live a long life.
You know, I watched a
movie, which is rare.
I went to Helsinki and
got all my work done.
I've literally watched seven
movies in the last two years
and they've all been Europe
back to America flights
because of the way it works
out where I get my work done,
I get a good night's
sleep, I get on the plane,
I have seven hours.
I get two hours of the catch up
of the shit I missed overnight,
and then I have this window
and I'm like, what the fuck?
(group laughter)
And no Wi-Fi.
It's a complete, like, you know.
So I watch this movie,
did you guys see the movie
of the Indian
mathematician who dies?
- [Group] No.
(laughing)
- You did, DRock?
- [DRock] Yeah,
I saw it on the flight.
- From Helsinki?
- No, I wasn't there.
- Oh.
So there's just like some--
Yes!
- But on the way.
- So, some all time great
mathematician that's in Oxford,
but he passed away at 32,
that's probably the thing
that's most on
my mind right now.
Like, fuck, man, I have to
do this for me and humanity,
(laughing) that's how
big of an ego I have,
to stay alive for a long time
so I can see this through.
I know I'm on to something
so fundamentally different,
and I know that I can
inspire people to do it
'cause it's gonna have
the empire part, too.
See, that's what
people don't get.
The reason I'm gonna win
is because I've got both.
The honey part means that you
wanna go change the world.
The empire part means
you'll do it at all costs.
I'm neither.
It's cool,
it's really interesting,
because when I buy the Jets,
there's gonna be a lot of
nice people that are 13
that are gonna
think they can build
a nice, big business thing,
do it the right way.
I'm gonna redefine
what an entrepreneur and
businessperson is thought of.
I think I can do it.
(murmuring)
Yeah, I think so.
I think it's really different.
That's why I'm dangerous.
All the people that I'm
not as pumped with online,
watches, this and that, selling
stuff, they're scared of me
because I'm better at
their shtick than they are.
So I'm dangerous.
It's fucking fun.
- Do you have
many goals set up in--
- [Gary] Let me get the
guy behind you real quick
because he's been
so awesomely patient.
- Short back story,
basic question.
I am video production,
aerial, and design.
First year, Ramen noodles,
renting all my gear,
building clientele.
Last two years, a lot of
success, 16 to 18 hour days,
and my dream is not that
big, it's 5 to 7 people
all on the crew, doing bigger
than what I can alone.
- [Gary] Love it.
- How do I keep the momentum
and build that team?
'Cause I'm tired, I love it and
I keep going, but I'm tired.
- By eating
Ramen noodles longer.
(murmuring)
You know, give up
more money for yourself
and give them to people.
The 100 and the 67
that I just talked about.
I did it, man.
All my friends,
I built Wine Library from a
$3 to a $60 million business,
and got none of the fruits
that a 26-year-old dude
would love to take advantage of.
Didn't even fucking
step into New York City.
You know,
I started paying myself 280,
I hired Ray Prado.
Miss you Ray. You know?
You know what's cool
about my answer?
It's the only true
answer to your question.
Either you work and you're tired
so you can keep
more of the money,
or you don't have the
fruits that come along
with a little more money,
and the fruits
are very basic, right?
It's not like you went from
that to caviar every night,
it's just whatever
is a little bit better,
but you can get very used
to that better than before
and it stops you.
(murmuring)
This stuff is so basic.
It's basic, it's hard.
It's hard.
We're not wired for it.
We want stuff now.
But I just don't.
- What wines are
you drinking now?
- That's a good question,
wine's been a very
interesting journey for me.
Because I'm not in
the business anymore,
I like it again.
It's so fun,
I'm a customer again.
Actually, I'm a customer for
the first time in my life.
To answer your question,
weird shit, it's so crazy,
literally, it blows me away
that I'm going to say this,
this is actually very non-nerdy,
I'm embarrassed in my
wine-self, I'm really hot
on oaked chardonnay.
It's the thing that
I made fun of
for 10 years on Wine Library TV.
But that's just a palate change.
Like, I grew up my whole
life not liking chocolate
and liking the
other kind of candy,
and now I'm the reverse.
Palette's are, you too?
- [Woman 4] Mhmmm, same thing.
- Yeah, I don't even
know when it happened.
- [Woman 4] When I got
pregnant, that's how I got it.
(group laughter)
- Not me.
So, oaked chardonnays,
a lot of Piedmont wines,
a lot of barolos, I think
that's the next category to pop
like the way burgundy did,
low-production barolo.
- I brought some from
Finger Lakes for you.
- [Gary] I love it man,
Riesling?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Awesome, thank you
so much, that's very nice.
Let's keep it going.
- So I loved the document
Don't Create message,--
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
it resonated with me big time.
- [Gary] That was a
big game changer,
as a matter of fact, DRock,
we're doing a bad job
building on that momentum.
We need to do much more
content about that.
That has been a game
changing piece of content
for a lot of people.
- It was tricky because
I'm a creative director
(laughing) so I was like,
hmm, how do I not
create and perfect,
and I know you're just
like, ship it, get it out.
- I mean,
early Wine Library TV is...
- And that helped--
- They're hearing well.
- Inspired when
I saw you in the hallway.
What you do, are you
agreeing with me, like boom?
- And you know what's so
interesting about that,
you know me, if it wasn't
stat, it had no chance.
- Oh, sure.
- [Gary] You know?
Do you know how desperate
I am to go into that club
and do the reading for you?
It's just time, I can't win.
But you did it fast,
and we did it.
- [Woman 2] I loved it.
- And it's a really
interesting insight for you
because you lived it with me.
You wanted me to
go do that event,
we have a great little
rapport with each other,
I desperately want to,
I said I would,
I never like to go back on
my word, it destroys me,
but, and then that.
You know,
that's interesting, doing.
Doing is the only fucking game.
- [Woman 2] Yeah, and I mean,
I loved it because I got to see
a little bit more into you,
because I think you are so
incredibly generous and kind,
but when you started to
talk about your grandmother,
it just, everything
sort of melted away,
you were so happy,
and I really felt--
- And you know what's
interesting about it?
That's the grandmother that
I actually have publicly said
multiple times is not
a very nice person.
- [Woman 2] Well, I believe it.
- But where it went for me
is my grandma represents
the bigger thing, which is,
and I even get emotional
about it and I never do,
as you guys know, this
group of 13 characters
that came to this country
with nothing, zero.
Like, zero.
Zero, $100 because
we sold our shit in Italy
while we were waiting
to get to this country.
It was supposed to
be paved with gold,
but oh wait, it's the late
70s and it's a recession time.
Fucking grinded, forever.
These kids that are like, ugh.
Like, kids who grow
up in good families
and don't want to grind for
a year before they want shit,
this was 20 years of building.
I just dismissed a
$3 million business,
even the tone that
I brought it with,
that took my dad his whole
life to get to that point,
'cause that's what you
do when you have zero.
How dare I do that?
He had zero.
- [Woman] How do you keep
your kids grounded?
- You don't.
I'll get back to that.
- It reminded me of my
grandmother, they came with
that as well and
I got very choked up,
kind of like.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- But I am a very patient person
and I have been building
this live story-telling show
and podcast and
now we're starting
to do storytelling workshops.
I talked to
Steve and Claude here
about doing them here as well,
and I have started
talking to local partners
about how we can work together.
And with some of these partners,
their social media numbers
are off the charts
compared to mine.
And I know for
the podcast in order
to interest advertisers
that you need
to have a certain
number of listeners
and downloads
and all that stuff.
- I don't believe
that by the way.
- Okay.
I believe that that's the way
the majority of
the market does it.
I think that if you're a
really good salesperson.
Did you ever see the video
where I cold-called somebody?
(group crosstalk)
I think you could, so
you're so understanding
of this industry,
that's your break.
I think you should spend
an hour a day cold-calling,
cold pitching a sponsorship deal
on your podcast that makes
no mathematical sense.
- Well, it's like a local,
so I make ice cream cakes
for this show that I do
and there's a local place
who is blowing up right now
and they're very interested.
- Yeah but I would
go to Ben and Jerry's
and just see if
you can get 'em there.
- They're about to be as
big as Ben and Jerry's.
- But they're not.
- But they're
selling like crazy.
- But they don't have a $100,000
sponsorship check for you.
- [Woman 2] Right,
so then I'm wondering what,
I have a lot to offer
them I just wonder how do I...
- You ask them.
- [Woman 2] Obviously I have
no problem asking.
- I know, so go ask them.
- Then I have to figure out
the numbers and what we need
and all that kind of stuff.
- Don't sell them numbers,
you don't have them.
But not only that, that's
the module to get there.
Never sell on your weakness.
You shouldn't figure out any
numbers, you don't have them.
- [Woman 2] No I don't and what
got people excited about it,
at least locally is my
enthusiasm, my passion,
I mean I have
an hour long meeting.
- I know you.
You better sell that.
- [Man 4] Can you
do for yourself
what you just did for her?
- [Gary] What's that?
- [Man 4] Most of
us in this room
can't see the forest through
the trees when it
comes to our own stuff.
- [Gary] Right, okay.
- But somebody else can,
I can sit here and
listen to anybody
and they can do the same for me.
Can you do that for yourself?
- I think that's what I did.
That's what I think I do best.
- [Man 4] Where does
that come from?
Is that who you are?
- Yeah, I think so.
You know, that's
actually what I do.
That's why I'm so
good at what I do.
I'm looking at me right now
just like you're looking at me.
And that talent
has been huge for me.
- [Man 4] How often do you?
- That's self-awareness
really, or a version of it.
- [Man 4] How often do they
call you out and say,
you don't see the forest,
these are just the trees?
Do they ever?
What does that look like?
- I don't even know if
they do or if they don't.
It's like literally white noise.
There's no executive
here or out there
that can possibly penetrate.
They just can't.
I haven't listened to
anybody in my whole life.
- [Man 8] Is that why your dad
let you take charge
of his company?
- Probably, you know
what's so funny?
I swear to God
I've never thought of this,
maybe I just took it.
Maybe he didn't give it to me.
(laughs)
I'm being dead serious,
I'm actually gonna ask him.
You might just
be right about that.
Maybe he didn't and the
truth is, knowing my dad,
he probably definitely didn't.
(laughter)
No question,
there's some of that.
Maybe my dad, you know
I was razzin' him in EQ,
maybe he understood there
was no other option.
Either that's what
it was going to be
or I was going to
go garage sale until...
I was willing to do anything.
I really struggled
entering my dad's business.
I didn't want that comment
on YouTube about the
three million, I didn't
want it because I know
I didn't need it.
Because I knew
it wasn't that much.
- [Man 15] Best place to travel
outside the United States?
- Turks and Caicos, and
I think the reason that is,
I've thought about this and
that's why I was able to
give you a follow up is
really hardcore, fond
family moments, you know
me and Lizzie by ourselves.
The kids,
one trip with my parents,
Mike Lazarou,
founder of BuddyMedia
had a place,
just real family.
Yeah, Turks.
- [Man 16] I got engaged there
two years ago, it was amazing.
Quick question, I'm in the
wedding industry,
grew up in a business,
took it almost from my father,--
- Yep, yeah.
- [Man 16] because
he had no choice
right it was kind
of that dynamic.
But the question I have now
is that in the entertainment
world we do mostly weddings,
and so within the wedding
industry everybody's a small
business, small photographer,
small DJ, small florist,
everybody's small.
What I've done now is I've
signed a 10 year lease
to build what's gonna be called
the wedding establishment,
and I vertically integrated
to create all these small
businesses under my
name under one roof.
The question I have is...
- You want to be Vince McMahon?
- Kind of, I want to
be Gary Vaynerchuk.
The thing is
reverse engineering it,
and if say in 10 years
I do want to sell it
at 7-10 million or whatever.
The fact of the matter
is that small businesses
in the wedding industry,
they just don't have that kind
of money.
Where would I go to sell
something at that level?
- So one thing that people
are confused by is who
might buy something in business?
Unlimited people.
First of all, you worry about
building a business that's
profitable, you can sell it.
I mean, what do you think
New York City is built on?
It's banking, it's, you have
a business that's profitable
you can sell it.
I'll buy it.
Because I'll look at it and
be like I can do that better,
and I'll buy it at what he's
got it at and I'll run it
through my machine and
it'll be worth a lot more.
- [Man 14] Vayner weddings?
- Interested.
(group laughter)
You know what I mean?
That's a really silly, and
by the way I say a lot of
silly things in the world
that I don't come from.
That's an unbelievably
silly question.
'Cause you're thinking
so micro, dude.
You can sell it to the guy
in town that's so impressed
who wants to buy a
business for his loser son.
- [Man 14] But the thing is it's
a wedding and there's no.
- I don't even understand
what you're saying.
- [Man 14] Okay.
- You are so micro-ed out.
I get it, okay.
- You should get it.
There's private equity,
there's banks, there's rich
people who have loser sons,
there's a wedding company
that you never heard of that's
going to become the uber of
weddings that wants it.
You have kids?
- 15.
- You have a 15 year old?
(group laughter)
I followed.
Them.
There's a million different
things that can happen.
You're caught so deep.
I wanna raz you because you
can take it, you're so deep
in it and it makes no sense.
- I just think
it's very specific.
- [Gary] Period, you just
thought, way too much.
- Sorry.
No, no it makes sense.
- [Gary] That's no problem.
Build a business.
- Yeah.
Everything else will be fine.
- Gotcha, love it.
- [Gary] You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I'm just pumped
for you, that's why I'm razzing
because that's
not a problem at all.
Cashing out is not a problem
when you have something
that's good.
Hey. One more here.
- [Woman 5] I have a small
family business that's about
three and a half years old now,
and the biggest issue we seem
to have is we have
minimum wage employees.
We are having problems
recruiting and retaining
them.
I never heard you say anything
about the lower paying jobs,
do you have any
advice on that?
- I sure do,
do you talk to them?
- [Woman 5] Yes.
- Do you really know
what they care and like?
- Yeah, I feel like I do, yeah.
- Well then you
should have no problem.
- [Woman 5] Even
with recruiting,
what I've found is go
through loads and loads
of different people,
you find one or two.
It's really difficult
to find those people.
With the low wages.
- How are you making
that decision when you go
through loads and loads of
people, to find that one
diamond in the rough?
- My gut, basically.
- You're overestimating
your gut.
I think I have the
greatest gut of all time.
I hire everybody.
You passed on the 10 best
employees you could have
ever had.
- [Woman 5] Okay.
- Got it?
- [Woman 5] Mhmmm.
- You have got to build
scalability in unscalable
things.
That's, as I'm thinking about
it, that's where I get it.
I do unscalable things,
but everything I do about
them is scaled.
Like it's kind of
interesting that way.
Let's go ahead, and then
we'll go over there.
- If culture's number one,
then what's your number two?
- [Gary] Culture.
(group laughter)
I mean, and then the other
thing that matters is
running good business, right?
But culture is number two.
Yeah, it's so big.
I mean I'm in the people
business.
The hell am I doing here?
But I did that with
Wine Library too,
even though we sold wine.
'Cause you're always
in the people business.
You can't fake environment.
My kids are going to grow
up on the Upper East Side,
go to private schools, have
friends that are on the
Aspen ski team but they live
in New York because they
take a private
plane after school
on Thursday and go to Aspen.
This is real.
I'm gonna be ridiculously
famous and wealthy.
I'm not gonna be able
to fake environment.
I need to teach them truths.
But are they gonna
be as hungry as I am?
Unlikely.
Maybe, maybe it's just a
hardcore DNA thing and they
were able to overpower
environment.
Maybe they look at my
mountain and they say
"Fuck you, Dad.
I'm gonna climb it."
Like I did.
Jesus Christ,
my dad seemed really
successful to me because that
was my context, I didn't
know about the Zucks or
Bill Gates.
I didn't think about that,
so you just can't fake
environment though.
And that's why I always
laugh at these rich parents
because they try,
and those are tactics.
We're gonna send them to a
camp in Maine this summer
that doesn't have
air conditioning.
Oh yeah, Johnny is really
gonna be hungry.
I mean, are you kidding me?
Alright hold on, one second.
Let me get here
and I'll come back.
- [Alex]Cabe is a middle school
principal,--
- [Gary] Cabe?
Oh, damn. But respect.
- [Alex] He teaches
entrepreneurship.
If you ran your own middle
school, what's the first class
you would drop and what
would you replace it with?
- That's a great question.
I would drop, first
class I would drop, fuck,
it's interesting, I respect
and disrespect them all
equally in some weird way.
I would audit every kid,
one by one,
figure out what they were weakest at
and make them drop that.
Then make them double down
on what I thought they
were strongest at.
That's the game.
I'll come back to you next.
- [Woman 6] How do you ignore
what everybody else is doing
and not compare
yourself to anybody else?
- Because I think
I'm better than them.
That's a really tough
thing to even say out loud,
but it's the truth
to your question.
I just do, it's so crazy.
Back to the SaaS product,
I'm sitting on this
perfectly parented because
I know it could be all time.
But I've got to really
give it my all.
I could half ass crush it
and it's gonna be a monster,
and real valuable, but I've
gotta really, really drill this
perfectly parented because
it could be all time.
Like all time.
Like, Bible, perfectly parented.
- [Man 6] Spring 2007,
can you tell us
when your parents comes out?
- Is that right?
- [Man 6] Yeah, I wrote it.
Love it,
I think I can write it better.
(group laughter)
Because you know the
truth is nothing we do,
nothing, all this stuff
has been said, and
then that's the,
you know what I mean.
Love that and I believe
that, but like everybody's
got their version of it.
I feel it deep within my
soul I got good one in me,
I can't wait to.
But that's awesome,
man I love that shit.
- This is from Matthew.
What's the next big advertising
platform you see coming,
Twitter is struggling,
Reddit just came out
with interest based ads,
and Snap is teasing
us with ad platforms.
Facebook ad costs are going up.
So I'm trying to see
down the road.
- I don't know.
I think Facebook is
grossly under priced.
I think influencers are
I'm not worried about
who's doing what next.
I just don't have a care,
I have zero interest in
what's next,
I only care about what's now.
It doesn't matter.
It'll matter when it happens.
- [Man 6] And that's what
you sell your clients?
- 100%.
I don't sell, VaynerMedia
doesn't sell the future.
VaynerMedia sells the now.
It feels like the future
when you do television and
direct mail and outdoor.
(group laughter)
I sell the now, always have,
most practical guy in the room.
Don't have the personality
that feels practical.
And most people don't
think it's practical because
everybody plays in the past.
Because the past
is for average players.
The data, data told you
what happened,
not where it's going.
Big data is a farce,
you have to interpret it
and make a decision.
- [Man 8] When you're
strategizing with companies,
do you ever tell the CEO's that
they should build their brand
because I feel like it's such
a huge underutilized platform.
Like traction channel for
a company, like why aren't
more executives
building their brands up?
- I really don't.
It's not what we're
being hired for.
VaynerTALENT might be
interesting, we might have a CEO
from Hewlett Packard
that wants it.
- [Man 8] They have literally 50
Twitter followers sometimes.
- Yeah, I mean they don't care.
Do you know how many
people make $91 million
a year that you've
never heard of?
- [Man 8] Mid- sized businesses,
don't you think the traction
channel they can--
- I do, but do you know how
many people are introverted
and not interesting and
don't like people, bad dudes?
- [Man 8] Like 7%, 30%...
- I agree I tell them every day.
They can find me.
You know what I mean?
It's out there, I believe in it.
Yes I do, I think they should.
- [Man 8] It's something
everyone else is doing in
marketing and sales,
but there's not this much
competition in that space.
- You're right.
I'm just not interested in
convincing anybody to do
anything kind of, I have
this weird non-sell thing.
You know?
I just viscerally hate to sell.
People don't get it.
- [Man 9] Is it because
you're so good at it?
- No, I wish that was it.
That's a cool, I may just
take that because it's cool.
(group laughter)
- No I just don't like it.
- [Man 9] Because it's
manipulation?
- No it's like I just don't
want anybody to have the
leverage, and if you're asking
the other person
has the leverage.
You know?
So I just sell on
having it come to me.
So if a CEO emailed me and said
I want to build my personal
brand, I'm thrilled to
have that conversation.
But I'm not gonna tweet you
and be like, "Hey Rick."
You know?
- [Alex] It's from Kellie Kelly.
- Kellie Kelly.
- [Alex] I'm struggling to
convince clients the value of
putting out digital content
consistently as you explained
brands having to become
their own media outlet.
How important is
it to story tell?
I am struggling to convince
them that this is the way.
- You're selling the wrong
people, Kellie Kelly.
Find the ones
that are sell-able.
That's just it.
I mean I'm sure as people
have gone down my rabbit hole,
the thing that's probably most
interesting is two things,
I think I'm asking
you guys actually.
One, how historically
correct I was.
And two, how very little
has changed in my message
over the last decade.
And that's it.
I don't think you should
sell to people that aren't
sell-able to.
You should find every person
that believes in e-comm
instead of convincing people.
Do you know how many people
believe in e-comm that you
haven't talked to yet?
All of them.
- [Man 7] Gazillion.
- All of them.
To spend one minute on
trying to convince somebody
that believes in something
else, e-comm is not smart.
It's bad strategy.
- [Man 10] Text messaging,
so we're here, this is the
ultimate, access is the
ultimate thing, right?
The explosion of messaging apps.
WhatsApp, Messages,
Snapchat, all that stuff.
How can you leverage
that without sacrificing
your sanity and all your time?
Do you even think about that?
- What do you mean?
- [Man 10] So, there's a guy
right now, he started a,
I don't see anybody doing
anything like this at all,
he started, rather than
doing a Facebook group,
he says I'm gonna
do a Facebook chat.
It's annoying because I'm
always getting notifications
popping up, but I see.
- Let's stop there.
- [Man 10] Yeah.
- That's gonna play itself out.
- [Man 10] His thing is
gonna play itself out?
- For you, because the
first word out of your mouth
is it's annoying.
So you're valuing it
as a marketer because
you're seeing it a lot, but
seeing it and consuming it,
seeing it, consuming it, and
acting on it are two very
different things.
- [Man 10] So let me set it up.
- Go ahead.
- I get energized by my
students contacting me and
just like you get energized
and telling me, "Man I did
what you said and it worked."
- I mean, you guys remember,
for a few minutes tested
V-chat, fake little app,
go ahead.
- [Man 10] I get energized
by that kind of stuff,
but I cannot scale that.
I've got 30 students
now right, but when I've
got 300 there's no way
that I can make that happen
unless I have them
pay for that access
so that's one avenue,
but is there a...
- You're looking for a
scalable version, what are you
going to sell your message
app that can answer
the questions for $19.99?
- [Man 10] No I'm looking to
charge myself up, but I don't
know how to do, and messaging
is an amazing way to.
- Give them your cell number.
(group laughter)
- [Man 10] I just think that
text messaging is so huge,
but I don't see anybody
effectively scaling it.
- Okay.
- I got to think about
this a little bit more.
- Let's stay on it for a minute.
Either you don't, you're not
telling me the full story
and it's not just about
getting charged up, which is
what I think, or you are
a person that needs to see
somebody else do something
to give you belief in it.
Both are bad.
So which one is it?
- [Man 10] There's probably
a little bit of truth
in the second one.
- Good, good, that's fine.
And by the way there's nothing
wrong with fast following.
- [Man 10] Yeah.
- It's not as good as
being the first one,
but it's super fine.
And if you're better
at it, it's even better
so go ahead.
- [Man 10] But I truly,
I feel like my purpose
outside of being a father--
- Yes.
- [Man 10] is not necessarily
fulfilled, but I feel like
I'm getting closer to
realizing my purpose.
- Which is?
- [Man 10] To help people get
unstuck from stupid things
that prevent them from doing.
- So let me ask you a question.
If that's your purpose
my friend, why don't you
do it for free like I do it?
Since it's my purpose too.
Purpose?
It's your purpose.
If it's free you'll
have more people.
Now show me in your actions
that it's actually your purpose.
- [Man 10] Yeah.
Yeah, that's good.
- Cause it's the truth.
Your purpose doesn't
come with an asterisk
attached for 4.99 a month.
Not your purpose.
Your business does.
- [Man 10] Yeah.
- But please don't bullshit
me the difference between
your business and your purpose.
You know how much I could
charge for what we're doing
here right now?
A lot more than
the fucking three, four.
- [Man 10] Yeah.
- Is it your purpose?
'Cause if it is do it for
free and give everybody
your fucking cell phone number.
That's the the
realest shit man,
you know what I mean?
- [Man 10] Yeah.
- And by the way, it doesn't
have to be your purpose.
You're not Mother Teresa.
Actually every time
I say that people get mad,
I guess she has
a lot of controversy
so I gotta find
somebody else, but
(group laughter)
but you know what I mean?
- [Man 10] Yeah.
Back to judging,
you don't have to but
you can have that conversation
with a lot of people,
I'm the worst guy to have
that conversation with.
On Earth.
'Cause I have the
most ability to charge
and I'm the only one
doing it for free at scale.
So you just walked into the
wrong guy for that conversation.
- [Man 10] Don't you
get annoyed with
the yahoos who
try to get your attention
who aren't willing
to do jack squat?
- I don't even know what
you're talking about,
that's how little
I pay attention.
(laughs)
I don't even know, you know.
I get worried 'cause
I know that that's happening
and a lot of
people are falling for it,
I get mad when people say to me
"Gary give me tactics."
I'm giving it to
them and then they're
getting it for free from
me and then paying somebody
$4.99 for their Snapchat
book, and all that guy did
was literally rip my
content and put into a PDF.
I get mad at
people's fucking stupidity.
And that's why
I'm gonna systematically
go one by one on
those fucking hucksters
and put 'em out of business
(group laughter)
over a 50-year period,
buy building the biggest
fucking empire on honey
to inspire other people,
be like,
wait a minute,
you can do that?
Yes, you can do that,
you can do it
by fulfilling your
purpose and then
selling something else.
That's just different
from everybody else.
It just is.
How are you my friend?
The second one's interesting
when you said
do I share the
P&amp;L with them?
- [Man 17] What are the
goals for the business
and how much do
you share it with them,
how do they know that they're
being treated appropriately?
I'm going through
this with my business
- Yeah, got it, that's an
interesting question, man.
So this is where,
it's very hard bro,
this is where you go
into the empire part.
I don't think I need
to open the books,
I'm comfortable with opening
them if I felt like I had to.
I don't trust the ability for
800 people to interpret it.
I feel great about it
because I don't know,
it's gotten better
for everybody,
and we're gonna make less
money as a company this year,
so it'd be a good time for
me to share it, you know.
Appropriate is
a one-person game,
if don't know if DRock
feels like he's being
appropriately taken care of,
but I try to have
that conversation,
I try to be the
kind of person that
you can have
that conversation with.
I mean there's a lot of people,
I've had a couple
of them this week
that I viscerally disagree with.
I feel like they're
over-compensated,
they feel like they're
under-compensated.
The good news in this scenario
is I'm the judge and
the jury, as they are,
they're more than welcome
to go out to the universe.
- [Man 17] How often are
you auditing your goals?
- I only have one goal,
stay in business,
and build the
capabilities to deploy
against the future behaviors.
Really.
I mean I dunno what else to say,
we literally flat out
made less money this year
at a hundred than
we did last year at 67.
For a lot of
people in this room,
especially based
on your questions,
that would be disastrous.
For me that's phenomenal.
- [Woman 2] You're just
investing in people?
- Yeah, just investing.
But you're asking a more
interesting question,
which is, whoever
you're worried about,
that disagrees with you,
that they're not
getting comp'd properly,
make a decision if you're
willing to reach those goals.
- [Man 17] It probably
has more to do with,
you know I am a follower mostly
for the business
sense that you bring.
- Yeah.
- [Man17] I love what
you talk about
employees, love what
you did at Wine Library
it means a lot
but for me as a business owner,
a new business owner
that you invest in these people.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Man 17] More than
you invest in yourself--
- That's how you
invest in yourself
- [Man 17] Right, I think of it
as an investment in myself--
- Of course,
but sometimes
you can't afford stuff.
- [Man 17] Sure.
- Like if I gave everything
everybody wanted here,
we'd close tomorrow.
- [Man 17] But I think
being transparent,
sometimes gives
them some perspective
on how much I'm putting into it--
- Show 'em.
- [Man 17] That's why I asked.
I don't think
people get it, though.
Like the biggest reason
I probably would never
share my books at scale,
is because if I decided
that in three years
to make 17 million,
I don't think my employee
that makes $140,000
understands the difference
between them and me.
- [Man 17] I didn't until
I was in business--
- You got it.
There's not an employee on Earth
that knows what it feels like.
That was such
a cool quote, that whole
sign the front of the check
versus the back of the check,
that was super gangster,
I like that.
Like, the don't know,
and by the way
they shouldn't know.
You don't know, until you do it.
You could dream about what your
first kiss is gonna be like,
you just don't know what
it is until you have it.
I figured out how to be a parent
because I was
11 years older than AJ,
and when I was
18 and he was seven,
I was really his parent, my ass.
I fucking walked into
Micha's fucking room
every day the first six months
just hoping she was still
breathing, you know.
- [Man 17] Yeah.
- You don't know.
And what you
don't know for sure,
is I thought, well after
they're seven I'll feel better.
I'm gonna be scared forever.
- [Man 17] Are you
scared for your business?
- I'm never scared in business.
Ever. Never have been,
never will be.
It's the thing I do.
I genuinely believe that
I'm LeBron and Beyonce,
I genuinely believe that.
- [Woman 2] What does scare you?
Health and wellness of
my family, nothing else.
Just I mean, what else?
Like what else?
And I've gotten
weirdly better at this,
I used to be really
scared of dying,
I brought up tonight
that I wanted to
live long enough
to see it through
but I'm less scared of dying,
which I don't really fully
understand yet.
Might just be, I guess
that's what happens, right?
It's the first time
in my life I'm like,
oh, that's why 87-year-old Rick
is like, "Meh." I get it,
that's kinda cool,
and different and interesting,
but trends are changing
and I want to be 120
and you know.
I mean, you want them
to have empathy for you,
and what you're dealing with--
- [Man 17] I want
them to know that--
- You want them to
have empathy for you.
As you should,
you know what I mean.
You want them to have compassion
for what you're dealing with,
you want them to know.
- [Man 17] I want them to
know I'm telling them the truth.
- I know.
- [Man 17] I'm investing
in the business and them.
- I know.
You remember being the
kid and not the parent?
Remember being a kid?
- [Man 17] Sure.
- You can only get so far.
You're only going to believe
your parents so much.
'Cause boy,
I'll get to you my man,
when you show them the books,
and then you find out that
Kristen whispered to Tyler
that you fudged the numbers,
your heart will break.
Do you know that
they don't believe me?
Do you understand?
Even in the best
agency you've ever seen?
They don't believe me.
They wait for every
moment to not believe me.
No, I think 'cause
they're jaded.
They don't believe me.
- [Man 11] Because of school?
- Because of the game.
The kids believe me
a hell of a lot more
than the 30 and
40 and 50 year-olds
that have been burned
by 17 other agencies.
Experience is what fucks you up.
I just know what you're in for.
I've been there.
If you want the good stuff,
it comes with
a lot of bad stuff.
- [Man 17] I love it all.
- Me too.
- [Man 17] It's happening
pretty soon,
and we're going
through a few things,
and I'm just curious how
much to share with them.
- That isn't the punchline.
The punchline is,
are you giving them
what they want,
on a one to one basis?
By the way, a lot
of times it isn't money.
- [Man 17] No, I know that.
- Good.
- [Man 17] It's responsibility.
- Whatever it may be,
whatever it may be.
Tickets to a baseball game, a
vacation, an acknowledgement,
there's just a billion
different variables.
Spend a lot more time
worrying about Susan and Rick
and less about the thesis behind
what you're thinking about.
And it will work itself out.
See where I'm goin'?
That's the winner.
How many employees you got?
- [Man 17] Five.
- How often have
you gone to dinner
one by one with the five?
- [Man 17] Not yet.
- That's insane.
- [Man 17] Yeah.
That's the answer, that's
where your problem is.
Five, I wish.
(group laughter)
Good, you know
how you get to 500?
By taking your five to
dinner every fuckin' day.
Really, you should really
go to dinner one by one,
you and Rick,
and you should go to dinner
once every four to six months.
And it should start with
like, tell me the truth.
I'm at a constant battle here,
to get them to believe me
that I want to hear it.
I'm not scared of anything
they're gonna say.
What the fuck
are they gonna say?
That I'm wrong?
I'm like good, you go build it.
That I don't get it?
I'm like,
I promise you I get it.
'Cause here's what I know.
The ones that have left, they
want to come back real bad.
That's the punchline.
You can't wonder
what they think.
You have to know
The problem is, a lot of
times you don't want to know
what they think.
Whether you know it
consciously or subconsciously.
- [Alex] Ireland.
- Ireland.
What's your name, my friend?
- [Evan] Evan.
- Real pleasure, thanks
for coming in, yeah.
Are you guys gonna hang out
with each other after I leave?
- [Woman 4] I think we should.
- I think people should.
By the way, I recommend
like smaller groups.
If you try to boil the
ocean it won't be as good.
- [Evan] I'm in the
health and fitness industry,
and we have nine different
Facebook pages.
- Okay.
- [Evan] And across
the nine pages
we've got
12 million followers.
- [Gary] Okay.
- And we're sending 500,000
clicks a day to
fitness articles.
But I kind of want to set
up a personal brand as well.
What would be the first
step you would take?
- What are you on?
- [Evan] I have
zero personal brand.
- You have zero personal brand?
- [Evan] Yeah.
- And you want to build
your personal brand?
- [Evan] Yeah.
- And what do you
want to talk about?
- [Evan] I'm not
really sure yet,
I need some work here on that.
- You better figure
that out, you know?
And I don't mean
like tactically.
Especially from a guy who is
behind a tactic based business.
You need to think higher up
what you want to talk about,
then talk about it, and then
use the distribution channels
to bring awareness to it.
- [Evan] Yeah.
- Don't forget,
I was the wine guy.
And then I started talking
about business content
and nobody wanted me to.
They said stick to
wine, wine guy.
Right, got it?
So you could talk
about flying kites.
I would still use your scaled
reach of the other channels
because some people are
into fitness and kites.
- [Evan] Yeah.
But would you start by
setting up a personal website
or would your
start with social media,
like set up an Instagram--
- Both.
- [Evan] Both.
- All of it.
- [Man 19] Thank you for Crush
It! and for all your stuff.
It's changed my life literally.
It's awesome.
- [Gary] Did Crush It!
change your life?
By the way, that's the punchline
while I've got all of you.
The book that I'm writing
next is called Crushed It.
And the subtitle is how
these 44, 17, 92 people
read Crush It! and crushed
it, and how you can too.
So anybody here
who has, not embellish,
don't do me any favors
'cause it will hurt me
if you're full of shit, and
we're gonna spend real time
trying to figure out
if you're full of shit
and if you told me that
Crush It! changed your business
and it didn't, then I'm really
never gonna talk to you again.
But if you were affected by
Crush It! with tangible results,
I wanna get those stories.
Please email me.
- [Man 17] I will.
- [Gary] Actually, email Alex.
(group laughter)
- It was good timing,
I read it in like 2011, 2012,
I created this product
out of my family business.
It's called Baking Steel,
it literally changed my life.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- It's awesome,
I have a blast doing it.
In my former life
I was a foodie,
so I've kind of combined--
- [Gary] I love it.
(camera movement
drowns out speaker)
- The good news is, I've created
this product for consumers.
But it's one off, I'm
gonna sell you one and--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Right, we have
a long term problem.
- [Gary] You either create
an ancillary product
that figures out how
to make the next step
or you are happy with being
the George Foreman grill.
- Okay, okay.
- [Gary] Or you do that and
you create something
completely different, and get
your creative juices nut off.
- [Man 19] Okay,
that's kind of what we're doing.
- [Gary] Yep, all of them work.
You just have to be good at
any one of those versions.
And a lot of times people
fail in that second product
'cause they use too
much of what made
their first product work
in their second product
without realizing the
differences in the world
from one to the other, or
the competitive landscape
of the new one.
- [Man 19] Mm-hmm,
sure, sounds great.
- [Gary] Good.
- [Man 19] And the
content part is awesome.
I want more of that,
because you can't do enough.
- [Gary] I know, listen, trust
me, back to ambition and...
You would not believe how
much I was like fuck man,
I wish I wanted a five pers--
I think that's awesome.
I'm not joking,
I'm convinced, convinced.
This is not even a debate
that I'll be 80 and be like
mm, wish I'd wanted
a little less,
could have done a little more.
I already do, I do now.
I don't have to guess.
This is not a joke,
and you're all gonna be
like "no, don't."
If a drug came out to
siphon out ambition DNA,
I would do it.
I'm telling you why, because
exact l y where I am now
I can settle into a four
to $13 million a year life
being just me.
Write one book, speak
140 times, and be done.
Still not siphon from
you and be good,
and fuckin' take
my kids on these trips
and fuckin' chill and not deal
with the fuckin' fires I'm
dealing with right now.
I got a lot of 'em.
I got five offices
and 770 people.
- [Woman] When are
you coming to Sydney?
- I was just there.
- [Woman] No, I know,
I was there as well.
- Oh actually, yes,
I remember now.
Actually, that's so weird, that
clicked for me a little bit.
That was cool,
I like how the brain works.
(group laughter)
- No I mean opening offices.
- [Gary] Oh, office.
There's gonna be a real battle
between Sydney and Singapore.
I'm fascinated to see how it
plays out for VaynerMedia.
I used to think
Singapore was gonna win,
now I think Sydney's gonna win
'cause I think we'll actually
just go directly into China.
We're gonna have to,
t here's no other way to win
in that market.
- [Woman] Cool.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Woman] Australia
I can live with.
- Yeah, I love,
I love Australia.
I mean that's, that to
me is such an easy market
because I'm cozy with
it from the wine world.
- [Woman] Yeah, and it's, it's,
and my world is payroll
in Australia, and we like.
Oh, that's terrible that
this is being recorded
because I was about
to tell you a secret,
but it's so, my business
is so easy because
I'm like in a market that's
20 years behind everyone else.
- By the way, by the way.
All of the markets.
You didn't say anything crazy.
Every market.
- I just thought I was.
- Nope.
All of them.
All the markets.
That's the crazy part.
If you actually deploy modern
tactics against any business,
it will work.
You got anything?
- Well, everyone kind of had
questions that were good.
You put out a lot
of content that's good.
But one thing, back to dads.
My dad, I turned him on
to your stuff obviously
when I said I was coming here.
He always says two
out of 10 people get it
and the other eight don't.
Do you believe that?
- I think the numbers
are way worse.
I think your dad's
an awesome optimist.
(group laughter)
You know, I think, I mean, look.
It goes back
to entrepreneur like
what's the definition of get it?
I think you got a good insight,
as much as you know me.
I'm pushing way harder than
you think on the heady shit.
Like I'm way up there.
I'm just trying to
stay down here
because I don't wanna get,
I wanna keep it
as practical as I can,
but like getting it to me
is literally, my definition,
care about nothing
except the health of the
people you love the most.
Zero.
Super interesting in theory.
What a wild game to do in
practice, like in real life
and execute on, you know?
I can't sustain stress.
- [Man 6] How do
you execute on that?
- [Gary] You know I don't.
Perspective.
Just dictatorship
around perspective.
If I had one employee,
if that sounded better,
and then a trillion.
If I bought the Jets.
I've said this.
I know some of you've heard it.
If I bought the Jets tomorrow,
and I got a text that Xander
got hit by a bus and died,
the fuck do you
think I'm gonna do?
Think I'm gonna be pumped about
the Steelers game next week?
I may never recover.
The fuck's the
matter with people?
If all five of your employees
hate you with their guts
and were gonna leave tomorrow,
I promise you that's way
better than the person
you love the most
dying tomorrow.
So I don't know,
understand why one would.
But we do not act like that.
We do not act like that.
We don't act like that.
And that's it.
Now, when I put on my jersey,
which is what
I'm doing right now.
When I'm in it, I'm in it.
But it's like
this fucking parallel.
Like it's like the programs
that run behind the scenes
on your computer.
Like there's a parallel
thing that's going on with me
that's just always
has that in mind.
It doesn't take away from
me wanting to destroy
everybody and fucking
deal with everybody
and do my thing.
I'm not leaving anything
on the field with you
in these two hours.
But it's running.
You know?
It's fucking running.
Emailed, newsletter.
(inaudible talk)
It was The Hustler Digest?
Yeah.
- [Man 18] So I'm like okay,
did you go back to automation?
Did you think that
the audience could ...
- No, because I don't
think there's anything
I'm doing in that email
that makes you think
I'm personally
sending you that email.
Like when you
signed up for it, it said
it's an email newsletter
that comes out once a week.
I don't like when people
try to use automation
to trick you into
thinking it's them.
I was curious if you were
gonna go down that path.
You see what I mean?
I love automation.
I don't like when automation
is a front for actual.
And I've done a
bad job historically
creating that clarity.
I hope you got that one, DRock,
'cause that's needed out there.
You see what I mean?
That's all.
I don't like the
deceptiveness of like,
oh, when I would say
that story in my keynotes
about like, then the emails
came out with your name on it.
They were trying to
act like they wrote it.
See where I'm going?
- That's all I have.
I just came to take in the view.
- Yeah, the view is.
- [Man 14] I'm curious
because what you just said
and the conversation on scale.
How many people here have got a,
any platform?
Because the attention game is.
You brought me
many different places.
How are you doing that a
direct contact from Gary?
- You mean like a heart on
Instagram and reply the email?
- [Man 14] Facebook,
Twitter, Snapchat.
Thank you, I watched it, TY.
Get this person contacted.
- Yup.
Yeah.
I email them.
- That's what's here.
I emailed Gary
about this whole thing.
- [Man 14] I got one
and it was an email.
My thing, what I think's
scary is we don't do that
in our businesses.
Now I run a brick and mortar
for fricking ten years plus.
- [Gary] I'm the busiest
of all of you.
(group laughter)
- [Man 14] We don't do that
in our own business with
our five or 50 employees.
- You know what's interesting?
You know what's
also interesting?
When I say, "I'm the
busiest of all of you",
and you made that face because
you're hustling your ass off?
The punch line isn't that
I'm actually the busiest.
It's just that I'm busy, so
busy that whether I'm working
18 hours and three
minutes and you're working
18 hours and four,
the punchline is
it can be done.
- [Man 14] The face was due to
what would happen if he
was around ten years ago?
That's the hustle.
That's the
difference in the hustle.
- You know what's crazy?
I work harder now than
I did ten years ago.
- [Man 14] Yeah,
but what advice
would you give
yourself now 10 years,
like from now and
when you look back.
'Cause you look back and
you think you work harder
'cause you're smarter.
- You think I'm smart?
- [Man 14] You're
way smarter today
than you were ten years ago.
- For sure.
But I'm also working harder too.
- [Man 14] Wine library videos--
- Yeah.
- [Man 14] To do my show.
- [Man 14] My ass
wasn't getting on video.
Until I saw that and go.
- He can do it,
that guy, I can do it.
(group laughter)
Yeah.
You know what's crazy is how
much harder I actually, harder.
And that makes sense.
That's why it's, it's like
momentum, like it's interesting.
I just think
it's so interesting.
Stuff that's tried and true,
I'm fascinated by that.
But you know, I'm really, thank
you for asking that question
because I don't know how he
caught it, but if we have
the right clip to that moment,
boy, there's a lot of people
that don't even do it once.
- [Man 14] Right.
- There's people literally.
Some of you have never
replied to a single comment
on a social media post that
you've made for your business
to somebody that replied to it.
- [Man 6] It takes
five seconds too.
It's like, why don't
they do it, you know?
- [Woman 3] Can I say
you referred to that
in the BeachBody speech.
- [Gary] Yes.
- 'Cause you went to people
and you said, "Hello."
- [Gary] I did.
I always do that.
I always do that
'cause I'm curious.
People.
When people leave.
I'm so weird.
I don't do a lot
of things I should do,
and I like I
do different things.
There's no reason for
somebody to leave a comment
on my Instagram saying,
"Learn the hustle from GaryVee."
And for me to
spend four minutes on that
in a world where, like
click on that person,
look at it.
You know?
Versus all the things
I should be doing, it's insane.
But it gives
me context, you know.
It's so interesting, but
boy, people aren't doing it.
People love to say it.
People hate to do it.
- [Woman] I mean think
about how good you felt
when you heard from Gary.
- Oh, the greatest.
I would shit my pants.
Listen, I wrote the blog post.
It's the Ricky Henderson effect.
That dude fucking winked
and it's been forever.
Fucking love Ricky.
A wink.
It's how I got
Oprah on Instagram.
Go look at Oprah's first
picture on Instagram.
It's me.
Fat me.
(group laughter)
I got it because I asked.
Like she was
trying to get, I was like,
"Do you ever wink
at anybody on set?"
She was like,
"What do you mean?"
I'm like, "Did you
ever wink at anybody
"while you were in
between commercial break,
"taping your show?
"The people in your audience?"
She goes, "Of course."
I'm like, "Do you understand
they've been telling
"that story for
the last 30 years?"
- So take one hour of whatever
the fuck you're doing,
and spend it on that,
over two and three and seven
and nine minutes at a time.
- [Man 4] Can I give you a
short little story real quick?
- Sure.
Where you talk about your mom,
'cause I'm still
trying to win her over.
- Oh, she's good, she's
starting her own business.
She's opening a
salon and everything,
and she loves the school,
and she's totally fine.
Thank you for your help.
But anyway,
so I was listening to Lewis's
podcast the other day.
Lewis Howes.
- Yes.
- And he had Elizabeth Gilbert.
- [Gary] I don't know
who she is.
What's that?
- She wrote like
Eat, Pray, Love.
- [Gary] Eat, Pray, Love,
yeah, big book, I know that.
- So she was giving--
- [Gary] I've heard of that.
- She was talking
about Oprah in it,
and she says, this is
why I love Oprah so much.
There was this
big conference she does
with like 20,000 people
speaking in stadiums,
and she got
this woman, this little girl
from Make a Wish Foundation
there, and everyone
gave her all their attention,
like she should stand up,
and Oprah said something.
That wasn't the real thing, it
was Oprah then said you know,
there's this other
girl that makes me,
really reminds me of
myself, she loves to read,
she's so passionate, and
she actually brought out
the girl's sister, who
doesn't get any attention--
- [Gary] Of course, yeah.
- Because the Make a Wish
Foundation wanted the girl
who gets all the attention,
and her parents
are so focused on her.
- [Gary] Of course, yeah.
- And she made that one girl
extremely special.
- [Gary] That's really cool.
- I had no opinions
towards Oprah at all,
but hearing that story,
I wasn't there,
I'm sure so many people heard
that, just that little thing
that she thought to do,
makes all the difference.
- [Gary] Yeah, and I was
super mad at Oprah.
Because that's easy, that's
the $50,000 donation.
What's hard is actually replying
to people on social media.
Everybody's got
different stories.
It's cool.
That's why I'm super
careful to judge anything
unless I really know it,
you know?
Life is interesting.
Sure is.
- [Woman 3] I have
one quick question.
- Please.
- [Woman 3] The stuff
that you bought on eBay,
- Yes. (chuckles)
- [Woman 3] Where
did you sell that?
I know on eBay, but--
- I gave it, I gave it
to my sister to sell.
Boy, I love that game.
- [Woman 3] It's fun to watch.
- It's just, you know, the
level you're playing out
with commerce
is a little bit different.
The Snapchat thing,
guys I'm getting emails from
people that are homeless
that made a hundred
bucks garage sale-ing.
It's game-changing.
Homeless.
That's actually, by the
way, that is my big little,
I'm going very micro right now,
trying to figure out this
homeless people
have smartphone thing
that I'm really,
I'm really into it.
I'm like, there
is something real here.
I need to figure this out,
the same way I won
on the Breakfast Club,
on like 20-year-olds,
I'm like, you know,
I don't want to be that guy,
like "I'm gonna help the..."
I'm not gonna sell my SaaS
product, but I'm gonna learn,
and I'm gonna learn,
and I'm gonna learn.
There's something really
powerful there.
It's the most powerful
device in the world
and so many people that
have the least have it.
Never in a time in life
has that been the case.
Gotta figure that out,
gotta figure that out.
I will.
The eBay thing is real.
It works on so
many levels for me.
DRock and I are gonna
do a full-pledged, all-in
DailyVee on garage sales.
It's gonna be, following
me to the garages.
I addressed this
on one of the episodes.
There were people that said
I staged it. (laughter)
What the fuck's the matter
with people? (group laughter)
They're like
"There's no way there's tags
"on this, from a garage sale."
I'm like, "have you
been to a garage sale?"
People sell brand new shit
they've never even opened.
We're Americans, we buy
shit and don't even use it.
Anyway,
we're gonna tape
the whole thing,
I'm gonna post it,
and then we're gonna, it's
gonna be the whole thing.
- [Woman 5] You're so right,
'cause I have three kids--
- Done.
- [Woman 3] And after I watch that
- But at the right time.
- [Woman 3] After I saw that,
I went through my three kids'
stuff and found so
many things with tags,
and I was like oh my gosh,
eBay, this is it, this is it.
And I decluttered
a whole bunch of stuff--
- [Gary] I asked Misha
the other night,
Misha, what have we learned
from garage sale-ing?
She goes, that you can get
better deals at garage sales
than the toy store.
(group laughter)
That's right,
can't teach environment,
but you can create
new environments,
little micro
environments, right?
Shit.
I love you guys.
Thank you.
(group applause)